so if you're going to have a country the
size of a continent and we do thank
kevin you need consistent and reliable
air travel it's not a luxury it's a
necessity the economy depends on it
and yet under this administration the
network the very delicate and functional
network of air travel that we've built
up over nearly 100 years is falling
apart
skywest airlines is the biggest regional
airline in the country they've just
announced they have a major pilot
shortage are planning to drop service in
29 different cities southwest all sorts
to announce slashing flights in april
and may because of staffing problems
it's not just staffing this caused them
the vax mandates didn't help at all
this is all going about to get much
worse according to one aviation
consulting firm we're going to be short
20 000 pilots by the end of this year
within just six years we'll be short
more than 60 000 pilots
so we have a transportation department
that works pretty much full time on
eliminating racist roads and other
equity agenda items mayor pete of course
runs it are they doing anything about
this problem jason rantz is radio show
host he joins us tonight with the report
hey jason
hey tucker yeah you're right the airline
industry is crumbling and buddha judge
is lecturing us about racist highways
which kind of makes sense if you're a
green new deal evangelist who doesn't
actually want us flying much which is
exactly what he's getting tens of
thousands of flights are being canceled
thousands a week are being delayed
making travel extremely difficult
especially in some of the smaller cities
that you would think p buddha judge
might pay attention to good luck flying
from north texas to louisville on
southwest airlines some day flights were
just cut american airlines slashed about
seven percent of its schedule this month
alaska allegiant 5
united for the year is getting some 20
000 flights largely due to a staffing
shortage from the coveted vaccine
mandate certainly one that was made
worse as a result airlines were
downplaying all those terminations
liberal reporters frankly supported the
mandate so they never did much digging
but as of january there were 31 000
fewer full-time airline workers than
before covid and while we were told
pretty much everyone was complying it
turns out a lot of people were also
quitting or retiring early it's gotten
so bad that jetblue is basically begging
flight attendants to take on some open
shifts alaska airlines is paying double
to take on extra work but it was the
number of retiring pilots that is the
most alarming obviously no flights means
no pilots means no flights alaska cut
flights from portland to denver united
cut from dulles to pretty much a bunch
of destinations and what you mentioned
with sky west they're looking to cut
federally subsidized routes that connect
small cities to larger hubs so folks can
actually get places they're not
profitable because the customer base is
too small so the department of
transportation subsidize it but what
we're seeing are serious service impacts
and threats of losing flights to cities
like pueblo colorado mason city iowa
under buda judge all the d.o.t has done
so far was basically tell sky was hey
you can't ditch these routes until the
d.o.t finds another carrier to pick up
these flights however sky west only
wants out because of the same pilot
shortages that the other carriers are
having airlines right now are desperate
for pilots they're kind of going into a
hiring and training spree for pilots and
for some others they're paying more
they're lowering some education
requirements the regional carrier breeze
airways they're using the e3 visa
program to hire pilots from australia
and obviously this is expensive and it's
happening at a time where we're seeing a
price surge for gas
it's unbelievable so if vax mandates did
this to airlines let's say you applied
them to the navy seals on the eve of a
war
i wonder what would happen to your
military
justin rants appreciate it thanks so
much thanks tucker so ratings of the
oscars just decline every year because
watching and sip itself involve people
talk of themselves is not that
interesting so this year they had a
brand new idea let's do something so
degraded and violent on stage that
everyone will talk about us we're going
to talk about them too pierce morgan
joins us to dissect it he's also here to
tell us about his brand new show which
we're excited about that's next